let's go to our caller from four one
nine four one nine introduce yourself
and go right on ahead hi David I'm I'm
Ryan
do you think James Comey would run in
2020 and would he be a viable candidate
so no I don't think he would run and I
don't think he would be a viable
candidate is anyone even talking about
Comey running this is the first I mean
I've heard draft Comey 2020 type stuff
but I didn't think that it was a real
thing in any way um I've just heard some
chatter about it but I guess maybe it's
not as a realistic it'd be crazy I mean
whatever we think about Comey be like
well okay so the strongest case I could
make for Comey is that he's a lifelong
Republican that now is seen
sympathetically by many Democrats
because of his role in being fired by
Trump in the investigation right that
would be the argument for like crossover
appeal for Comey but the guy is
politically toxic at this point right
like I don't think I don't think there's
any benefit to a Comey candidacy in any
way yeah I agree I was just curious
about your community all right good glad
we agree thank you appreciate the call
call me 2020 yeah that's interesting